Nous allons leur faire des propositions.
Les propositions que nous faisons, elles sont simples,
le SMIC est indexé sur l'inflation, il a augmenté de 12%.
Nous demandons que l'ensemble des salaires soient
indexés sur l'inflation de la même manière.
Et nous demandons que les retraites suivent le même
mouvement et ça veut dire 12 pense
12% d'augmentation pour les pensions
et pour l'ensemble de nos retraités.
Nous demandons 1 conférence sociale
afin que l'ancienneté soit mieux prise en compte dans
toutes les branches,
toutes les protections,
de même que le niveau de compétence.
Nous demandons que les
formations soient reconnues et que chacun
puisse gagner en fonction de ses compétences et de son
expérience. Nous demandons qu'il n'y ait plus 1 seul
salaire qui soit versé en dessous du SMIG
car il existe encore aujourd'hui 1 cinquantaine de
branches où les salaires sont en dessous du SMIG,
ce qui est illégal.
Et c'est la loi qui doit rétablir
1 juste rémunération
et des salaires qui arrivent au moins au
niveau du SMIG.
Nous avons 1 grande bataille à mener dans notre pays
pour que le travail paye.
Alors le 1ère ministre,
il le dit à l'Assemblée nationale,
il faut que le travail paye.
Le 1ère ministre,
il le dit à l'Assemblée nationale
que la France est smicardisée,
mais c'est son bilan,
c'est le bilan de son gouvernement.
Depuis deux-mille-dix-sept
années d'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron,
le nombre de smicards dans notre pays est passé de 12%
à 17%. C'est le fruit de Sa politique
et d'exexonération de cotisation sociale
versée sans rien demander en échange aux entreprises.
C'est pour cela,
c'est pour cela
que nous voulons obtenir des mesures d'urgence
pour que le travail soit correctement rémunéré
et qu'en fin il y ait 1 juste répartition
de la production de nos richesses en faveur du
travail et non plus en faveur du capital.
Le c'est le capital qui coûte cher,
ce ne sont pas les salariés,
ce ne sont pas les services publics
et c'est pour cela que nous voulons
reprendre le pouvoir
et sur l'argent et sur nos richesses.